hello everybody and welcome to my
pay-to-play
money making guide for old school
runescape today I'll show you a method
that can make you upwards of seven or K
an hour or a little bit more possibly
depending on how full the shops are it's
really easy all you need to do is get
into the Warriors guild which you can
see I'm at right now to get in here you
need sixty five attack or strength or
ninety nine and one of them more likely
you're gonna have the sixty five each by
that yeah and if you have full graceful
or any weight reduction equipment is
really useful all I have is boots of
lightness so it's pretty bad so as you
can see all you're going to do is run up
to the potion shop buy all the strength
potion threes then you're going to run
over to this dude over here in the other
shop and you can buy all the tuna
potatoes and deplane pizzas then you
just gonna hop worlds and just repeat
this over and over again and that would
recommend starting with about 100k if
you have it in about an hour you'll
spend about 40k on all the ingredients
that you'll be buying so you really
don't need too much to start with here
and you can see right there I made 5k so
we get I'll put a timer on for 60
minutes I will kind of possibly do this
I'm not gonna try out it too much just
so you get a pretty accurate amount that
you should expect from doing this method
and I'll check back when the timer's
done alright see ya
all right so we're almost done here we
have about a minute left I've done
almost with a flower and I can say it's
it's definitely a little boring like
it's not the most engaging but it's not
as bad as crafting nature ruins at least
for me it's less stressful because you
don't have to go into the abyss or
anything and you're getting like 7 or K
an hour plus you'd only need the attack
and Schrank levels something that found
is the tuna potatoes in the plain pizzas
are bottled pretty frequently
I guess Iron Man and just other people
doing this will buy them but the potions
are not commonly bought out so it's
pretty consistent that way I would just
buy the potions but I've tried it and
you get booted off from logging in too
much because it's too quick to buy them
whereas when you're running back and
forth gives your client a bit of time to
reset I see I'm using OS buddy and using
the quick hop feature and if you do it
too much it'll just put you out for a
couple seconds which is rather annoying
that's why I'm running back and forth
between the two yes we're down to 20
seconds we'll just get a couple more
pizzas and potions and then we'll just
tally everything up and yes it is boring
I'm not going to deny that but it was
not too quick intensive actually I mean
you definitely have to focus but it's
really better than some and you were
getting 700k an hour so it's I think
it's pretty good and yeah that's it
times up so I will just quickly hop over
to Brock and we'll sell it all ok so we
are almost at Brock you can see we
managed to get 374 tun two potatoes 332
pizzas and 845 potions we spent 35 K and
all of them and I think that's pretty
average anyone could expect to get about
this much and yes we'll sell them off
here the tuning potatoes we go with
about 180 K the pizzas let's see here
two and forty a boat and the potions we
got the most of those 300 count God um
so yeah see what instantly sold all of
them with the collect button BAM 822 K
so yeah I can see we made 720 2k with
minimal requirements and that's just in
one hour and I'm sure if you had the
graceful set or any other better weight
reducing equipment this might even go
even quicker hi
do in the middle of the night I'm sure
he can make 900k maybe because I was
fighting with a good amount of people
the entire time just get the two new
potatoes and the pizzas mostly and I
still made seven okay so I think it's
already contested spot the prices aren't
really likely to drop that much because
there's so many of them traded every day
so I think it's a good method again the
prices might change it might not be as
effective all the time but the prices
you're buying from the shop you'll
you'll always be making money so there's
no reason not to give us a shot and so I
hope you guys can make up the money
doing this and I'll see you guys next
time